so now that we've spent some time
thinking about what a differential
equation is and even visualizing
solutions to a differential equation
using things like slope field let's
start seeing if we can actually solve
differential equations and as we'll see
different types of differential
equations might require different
techniques and solve them we might not
be able to solve at all using analytic
techniques we'd have to resort to
numeric techniques to to estimate the
solutions but let's go to what I would
argue is the the simplest form of
differential equation to solve and
that's what's called a separable
separable differential equation and we
will see in a second why it is called a
separable differential equation so let's
say that we have the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal to negative x
over Y e to the x squared so we have
this differential equation and we want
to find the particular solution that
goes through the point that goes to the
point 0 comma 1 and I encourage you to
pause this video now I'll give you a
hint if you can on one side of this
equation through algebra separate out
the Y's and the D Y so on the other side
have all the X's and DX's and then
integrate perhaps you can find the
particular solution to this differential
equation that contains this point now if
you can't do it don't worry because
we're about to work through it so as I
said let's use a little bit of algebra
to get all the Y's and dys on one side
and all the XS and DX's on the other
side so one way to if I want let's say I
want to get all the Y's and dys on the
left-hand side and all the XS and DX's
on the right-hand side well I can
multiply both sides times y so I can
multiply both sides times y that has the
effect of putting the Y's on the
left-hand side and then I can multiply
both sides times DX I can multiply both
sides times DX and we kind of treat you
can treat these differentials as you
would treat a variable when you're
manipulating it to essentially separate
out the variables and so this will
cancel with that and so we are left with
we are left with y dy Y dy is equal to
negative x and actually let me write it
this way let me write it as negative x e
actually I might a little more space so
negative X e to the negative x squared
DX D X now why is this interesting
because we could integrate both sides
and now this also highlights why we call
this separable you won't be able to do
this with every differential equation
you won't be able to algebraically
separate the Y's and dys on one side and
the x's and DX is on the other side but
this one we were able to and so that's
why this is called a separable
differential equation differential
differential equation and it's usually
the first technique that you should try
hey can I separate the Y's and the X's
and I said this is not going to be true
of many if not most differential
equations but now that we did this we
can integrate both sides so let's do
that so I'll find a nice color to
integrate with so I'm going to integrate
integrate both sides now if you
integrate the left-hand side what do you
get you get and remember we're
integrating with respect to Y here so
this is going to be Y squared over 2 and
we could put some constant there I could
call that plus c1 and if you're
integrating now that's going to be equal
to now the right hand side we're
integrating with respect to X and let's
see you could do you substitution or you
could recognize that look the derivative
of negative x squared is going to be
negative 2x so if that was a 2 there and
if you don't want to change the value of
the integral you put the 1/2 right over
there and so now you could you could
either do u substitution explicitly or
you could do it in your head or you said
u is equal to U is equal to negative x
squared and then D U will be negative 2
X DX or you can kind of do this in your
head at this point so I have I have some
and it's derivative so I really could
just integrate with respect to that
something to with respect to that you so
this is going to be this is going to be
1/2 this 1/2 right over here the
antiderivative this is e to the negative
x squared and then of course I might
have some other constant I'll just call
that c2 and once again if this part over
here what I just did seemed strange the
u-substitution you might want to review
that piece now what can I do here we'll
have a constant on the left hand side
it's an arbitrary constant we don't know
what it is I haven't used this initial
condition yet we could call it so let me
just subtract C 1 from both sides so if
I just subtract C 1 from both sides I
have an arbitrary so this is going to
cancel and I have C 2 sorry let me so
this is C 1 so these are going to cancel
and C 2 minus C 1 these are both
constants arbitrary constants we don't
know what they are yet and so we could
just rewrite this as on the left hand
side we have Y squared over 2 is equal
to on the right hand side all right 1/2
e let me write that in blue just because
I wrote it in blue before 1/2 1/2 e to
the negative x squared and I'll just say
C C 2 minus C 1 let's just call that C
so if you take the sum of those two
things let's just call that C and so now
this is kind of a general solution we
don't know what this constant is and we
haven't explicitly solved for Y yet but
even in this form we can now find a
particular solution using this initial
condition let me separate it out this
wasn't part this wasn't part of this
original expression right over here but
using this initial condition so it tells
us when x is 0 Y needs to be equal to 1
so we would have 1 squared which is just
1 over 2 is equal to 1/2 e to the
negative 0 squared well that's just
going to be e to the 0 is just 1 so it's
going to be 1/2 plus C and just like
that we're able to figure out if you
subtract
one half from both sides see is equal to
zero so the relationship between y and X
that goes through this point we could
just set C is equal to zero so that's
equal to zero let's see oh right over
there and so we are left with y squared
over two is equal to e to the negative x
squared over two now we can multiply
both sides by two and we're going to get
Y squared Y squared let me do that so
we're going to get Y squared is equal to
is equal to e to the negative x squared
now we can take the square root of both
sides and you could say well look you
know Y squared is equal to this so why Y
could be equal to the plus or minus
square root of e to the negative x
squared of e to the negative x squared
but they gave us an initial condition
where Y is actually positive so we're
finding the particular solution that
goes through this point that means Y is
going to be the positive square root if
this was the point 0 negative 1 then we
would say Y is the negative square root
but we know that Y is the positive
square root it's the principal root
right over there so let me do that a
little bit neater so we can get rid of
whoops that was writing in black so we
can get rid of this right over here
we're only going to be dealing with the
positive square root or we could so we
could write Y is equal to e to the
negative x squared to the one-half power
and that of course is equal to is equal
to e to the negative x squared over 2 so
this right over here is or y equals y
equals e to the negative x squared over
2 is a particular solution that
satisfies the initial conditions to this
original differential equation so just
like that because we were able to just
as a review because this differential
equation was set up in a way or because
we could algebraically separate the Y's
dys from the X
DX's we're able to just separate them
out algebraically integrate both sides
and use the information given in the
initial condition to find the particular
solution